[Captions by Judy V. at Y Translator]
Today, we'll be taking
the flame thrower arm
that we built in the previous video,
and decorating it to make it
look a little bit more finished.
[Music]
Our flame thrower arm
is built and functional.
It's up and running.
But at this point, it does look
thrown together, which it is.
And if you like
the mad scientist look,
then this is doing pretty good.
But I think what I want to be going
for is the cartoon Mad Scientist look,
so I want to make it look all sort
of sleek and carefully put together.
Here's what we're going to do.
We've got some craft foam
that we'll cut, glue, and paint,
and then attach onto
the flame thrower arm
to hopefully make it look
like a slick finished product,
rather than the thrown together
workings of a mad engineer.
There will be two basic
sections divided at the hinge.
We'll have an upper arm portion,
and a lower arm portion.
These sheets of craft foam are
something that I love to use.
I've used them quite a bit.
They're quarter of an inch thick.
I get them at Hobby Lobby,
where they cost $1.27 each.
We've got a bunch of them,
and now, we need to make them
look like something really cool.
The wood frame that I have here
holding the bottles in place,
so I think that's kind
of going to be a guide.
I'll try and make the foam
rest right up against that,
that'll give it a little bit of support.
You can see that this upper arm portion
is going to end up being fairly large,
but overall, this is going to look
like a giant, bulky, crazy thing
that's going on my arm,
which is what I'm hoping for.
[Music]
This handle's gotta be
able to move in and out.
When its open, it fits.
But when I close it, it runs into the foam,
so we'll cut a little space for that.
And we won't just leave that open.
I'll end up going in and adding
some other little Ironman type box
to go around that or something.
[Music]
All right.
It's not like completely
strapped onto my arm.
I'm holding it with my
other hand at the moment.
But it's just a test fit with all of the
built on armor elements just to look good.
The lights are going a little bit.
Now, I need to take all the
decorative armor portions off,
paint it all up,
put it back on,
and attach the lighting
in a little bit more permanent way.
And at that point,
this sucker will be good to go.
Step 1, painting this foam is going
to be to hit it with the heat gun.
We'll then go over it with
a couple of layers of Plasti-Dip,
then a primer, and then our colors.
[Music]
At this point, the cover piece that goes
on top of the flame thrower is now built.
It's wired up with some electric lights,
checking control with
a little knob on the side.
I think it looks great.
It looks metallic.
It looks really cool.
Very cartoon evil
mastermind sort of thing,
which is what I was going for.
Got our dragon logo here on the side.
Let's fit this bad boy on.
The two exhaust burners in the back
actually just fit right
over our propane tanks,
and then we've got a little
circle up here in the front
that fits right over our solenoid.
Once all three of those
connection points are on there,
it actually does a pretty
good job of staying on.
Pretty nice and snug.
The hinge in the cosmetic arm
lines up pretty nicely with the hinge
and the functional part of the arm.
Let's strap this thing on and give it a test.
[Music]
Open the valve so we're
taking fuel from both tanks.
[Music]
Yeah!
It's so great!
[Music]
Guys, check out the other videos
where we showed you how we built
the internals of the flame thrower,
and of course, where we just went out,
and showed it off using
the thing, burning stuff.
All that good fun.
Guys, we've always got more
cool content for you to see.
Check out more of the
flame thrower here on the side,
and if you hit this bomb in the middle,
you'll do subscribe to our channel
so you never miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.